I hope you're okay today I know
sometimes things can be difficult but
I'm here for you full disclosure I am a
big fan of Detroit become human
I loved heavy rain and even though I was
disappointed by beyond two souls Detroit
recovers what makes Quantic Dream games
excellent deep stories complex
characters stellar performances and
branching options which make it feel
like you're in control of the narrative
unfortunately with Detroit I feel like
Quantic Dream grabbed on to that last
point and took it a few steps too far
with the heavily marketed flowchart
mechanic which shows every branching
story possibility now I didn't mind the
flowchart when it was shown in the
trailers I get it Quantic wanted to
prove that your actions have
consequences and that they will alter
the course of the game for as long as
there have been choose your own
adventure games there's been the gripe
from plays that your actions actually
don't change the story that much at all
it seems like the flowchart was included
as a tool to head that argument off at
the pass
which in theory I don't have an issue
with unfortunately the way the mechanic
has been implemented in the game hurts
the experience of playing it after you
complete a chapter in Detroit you're
shown a flowchart that details exactly
what you did and what you didn't do you
can also access worldwide statistics in
there so you can see what everybody else
did sometimes these charts are
staggeringly complex and sometimes
they're so flat you'll wonder why they
needed to be shown at all while this is
intriguing in the same way that seeing
statistics at the end of a telltale game
is intriguing it's also extremely
effective at destroying your immersion
in the events unfolding particularly
when you learn that the flowchart can be
loaded up from the pause menu with
real-time data at any point during a
scene at the end of every beautifully
crafted gorgeously animated and
sometimes confronting scene you're
forced to watch a chart unfold that
screams you are playing a video game
here are all the possibilities and
outcomes we programmed in beyond that
you're also awarded points for every
action you performed which include
crossing off optional objectives and
even something as trivial as breeding a
magazine furthering my bemusement
these points can be spent back
the main menu on screenshots trailers
and other assets I understand that this
is designed to encourage you to replay
the game and collect every possible
action but I question whether this is
something players actually want okay but
you know what your doctor would say yeah
oh he can kiss my ass
I'm old enough to choose my own
medication in my mind choose your own
adventure players are divided into two
groups those who must see every little
thing the game has to offer and those
who prefer to play through organically
knowing that the decisions they make
create their personal story
there's a reason telltale ops to present
this kind of data at the end of the game
instead of in-between every new sane and
detroit's frequent data heavy intrusions
illustrate that reason perfectly it's
like pausing a movie after every scene
to check IMDB for the production notes I
am a completionist when it comes to most
games but not choice driven adventures
where you're encouraged to carve your
own path it's a shame when you reach the
end of a combination of personal choices
and the game appears to judge you for
what you missed out on it puts a dour
and your achievements and instead
highlights your completion rate another
reason the mechanic bothers me is that
flowcharts could be thrown into a lot of
games and doing so in Detroit seems to
suggest a lack of confidence in ensuring
its players know they have options
take divinity original sin - or The
Witcher 3 for example these games have a
lot of branching outcomes and could have
chucked in flowcharts far larger and
more complex than those in Detroit but
they don't feel the need to prove it
choice is an important part of Detroit
become human
but the flowchart mechanic detracts from
the game's best qualities Detroit shines
because of its living breathing world
it's stunningly written characters and
its investigation mechanics which are
executed far better than they ever have
been in previous Quantic Dream games
[Music]
these are the things that encourage
players to revisit a game a world and
characters that pull you in and make you
curious to see more trading stories with
friends about alternate routes is a far
more natural way of discovering the
choices you could have made then a flow
chart full of data and I wish Quantic
Dream had left them up to the players to
engage with as much or as little as
they'd like oops I think your savegame
is corrupted just kidding
you